[Music]
Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy now here's a new twist The
Establishment propaganda media's
narrative that Muslims are always
victims is breaking down with the
continuing Revelations that Muslims have
faked anti-muslim hate crimes and so ABC
News has come up with a new idea and
doubled down Muslims are victims they
tell us because they fake anti-muslim
hate crimes you see they're Driven Crazy
by
islamophobia this wild idea comes from
none other than the Council on American
Islamic relations spokesman Ibrahim
Hooper affectionately known as Hest says
heste these false reports unfortunately
give ammunition to the industry of
islamophobes who promote the
demonization and dehumanization of
Islamic Muslims
Islamic Muslims that's really how ABC
News quotes Hooper are there non-islamic
Muslims now anyway notice how deafly
Hooper plays the victim card even in the
process of being exposed for falsely
playing the victim card the fake hate
crimes you see are not a challenge to
the veracity or trustworthiness of
Muslims rather they are tools in the
hands of the alleged islamophobes who
supposedly promote the demonization and
dehumanization of of those Islamic
Muslims as if it's demonizing and
dehumanizing someone to ask him to be
honest Hooper added that the Muslim
Community is under great psychological
stress and tension right now and that
that in itself can cause mental health
issues that lead to these types of
incidents now why is the Muslim
Community in Hooper's view under great
psychological stress and tension because
of all the hate crimes against Muslims
you see which Drive Muslims so crazy in
Hooper's view that they fake hate crimes
against
Muslims now I wonder how did avn10 the
ABC news reporter who was interviewing
Hooper keep from laughing right in his
face she either kept a straight face
because she's a fully indoctrinated True
Believer in this politically correct
nonsense or because she knew that her
establishment propaganda media bosses
would look a scance at her thinking
critically in the face of Hooper's
ridiculous statements but it is
understandable why he said what he said
Hooper had to do what he could to shore
up his failing narrative hate crimes
after all are political Capital when
real ones don't exist they must be
invented the Hamas link Council on
American Islamic relations and other
Muslims have on many occasions not
hesitated to stoop even to fabricating
hate crimes including attacks on mosques
a New Jersey Muslim was found guilty of
murder that he tried to portray as an
islamophobic attack that I myself was
blamed for and in 2015 2014 rather in
California a Muslim was found guilty of
killing his wife after first blaming her
murder on islamophobia I was blamed for
that one too this kind of thing happens
quite frequently the New York daily news
reported that a woman who told cops that
she was called a terrorist and slashed
on her cheek in lower Manhattan later
admitted she made up the story the woman
who wore a hijab told authorities that a
blade wielding wacko sliced open her
face as she left a Manhattan cosmetology
school
sounds terrible but it didn't happen we
were told that a Muslim boy was attacked
and beat up on his school bus in North
Carolina but a photo released at the
time showed him without a scratch and
Nar a person on the bus corroborated his
story and recently in Britain the murder
of a popular Imam was spread far and
wide as yet another islamophobic hate
crime until his killer was found also to
be a Muslim the mirror reported that the
Imam was targeted because he made
efforts to turn youngsters away from
radical Islam there's so many such
stories one celebrated one in New York
City recently involved a woman in a
headscarf who was supposedly attacked by
Trump supporters none of it happened and
according to the Detroit News a Muslim
woman named SAA chatty was charged with
making a false police report after she
allegedly fabricated a plot to blow up
Dearborn Fordson High School to
retaliate against the November to 2015
terrorist attacks in Paris Police say
chatty called Dearborn investigators
November 19th 6 days after Islamic
jihadis killed 130 people in Paris and
similarly in Britain a Muslim woman was
fined for lying to police about being
attacked for wearing a hijab the
18-year-old student known only as Miss
chowdery said she was violently shoved
from behind and punched in the face by a
man in Birmingham city center 10 days
after the atrocities in the French cap
capital on November 13th
2015 once again the only problem was it
didn't happen it's virtually certain
that we've not seen the last anti-muslim
hate crime that turns out to have been
faked by a Muslim being a victim is a
coveted status in our leftist dominated
Society even individuals in groups who
were not victims try to gain this great
honor for themselves it's easy to
understand why in light of Ibrahim
Hooper's statements once one is
recognized as being part of an
established victim group The mainstream
media will treat even one's most absurd
statement with respect bordering on
reverence it's a headyy status to
have it's no wonder that Ibrahim Hooper
would be fighting with everything he has
to maintain that status even as the
cynicism and dishonesty of his entire
Enterprise has been so abundantly
exposed I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]